der hand liegt es ist alles doof eines
brief luft so stellen organisieren
du musst dich dann ein richtiges richter
kommt man durch
september 2013
thomas [ __ ] präsident des vereins
flugschneise süd nein ruft zu dem seit
mehr als zehn jahren engagiert er sich
gegen fluglärm
was treibt ihn an warum gibt es eine
mission schließlich auf und kehrt der
schweiz den rücken
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
früh morgens um 6 uhr in fahrpausen
einem weiler der gemeinde fällanden
vor zehn jahren hat alles angefangen als
plötzlich jeden morgen jets im
landeanflug über die dächer des kleinen
dorfes donnerten sind riesig spätestens
beim zweiten ihr unterwegs
zehn jahre protest konnten das ungemach
nicht beseitigen noch immer landen die
flugzeuge jeden morgen von süden thomas
morf leitete eine edv gruppe einer bank
bevor er den 50 prozent job als
präsident des vfsn übernahm heute ist
sein büro zu hause seine widerstands
zentrale von hier aus führt der
60-jährige den kampf gegen die turbinen
begegnung ist in der grafik gegner
material flüge im verkauf und in zürich
auf reiche aus mit maus und vernunft als
erstes benötigt man von diesem morgen
eine rechtsauskunft das gab der uns
magen bezirksgericht uster und ich bin
eigentlich für sauer über die antwort
und mir ja ja genau
ja da bin ich für diese auge und mini
frage habe ich als rechtsanwalt eine
chance dass man die klage könne irgendwo
in mir
jetzt fühlt ob friedlich als die ganz
politik und der bundesrat
kunstvoll süddeutschland und und es ist
regen wir zweiter selber als kuschel
oder in seinem newsletter hatte morf
einen deutschen landrat provoziert indem
er ihn in einer karikatur als deutschen
taliban dargestellt hatte dies erreichte
am bezirksgericht uster eine
verleumdungsklage ein nun stellt sich
die frage sich gütlich einigen oder ein
urteil verlangen
thomas wolfs kampffeld hat sich
inzwischen ausgeweitet
ihm geht es auch um den rechtsstaat und
die demokratie muss ich aber ruhig
machen und auch musiker verliebt haben
häufig belehren meine universität
passiert glaube das sind etwas ganz ganz
wichtiger aspekt der bruch
thomas morf und seine frau esther leben
im elternhaus von esther auftrags über
ein idyllischer ort
der flughafen hatte im jahr 2003 die
morgendlichen südlondon im notrecht als
ausweg aus dem fluglärmstreit mit
deutschland eingeführt niemals hätte das
ehepaar gedacht dass ihr widerstand mehr
als zehn jahre dauern würde so eine
quarks südländische verstoßes gegen
diverse stieg 6 und dazu habe ich
geglaubt dass ich auch die obrigkeiten
wird die oster dachte immer jahr
vielleicht ändert sich dies auch gast
aus iserlohn verständlich dass man
wieder herein eindeutigen gesetzeslage
überhaupt nur dank des landes führen aus
der notlösung wurde zwar ein
dauerzustand aber für morgen kein
dauerthema
sitzung familie thema welle machen
handel zum familienunternehmen jährige
engagiert wie wir wirtschaften und ich
obwohl der kampf bisher nicht ans ziel
geführt hat kam aufgeben für thomas morf
nie in frage
das macht ihn für die einen zum helden
für die anderen zum sturen fanatiker
hatten spieler und ich weiß nicht was
mit dem von ihr ab und ich sage das als
kompliment
das heißt jedoch dass ich meine arbeit
gut machen dass ich dir was ich so
bedruckt oder sich dass ich die ja
bedürfen
wir sind mit thomas morf am ort des
geschehens im norden des flughafens
zürich-kloten
das ist auch der ort wo der flughafen
sieht seine betriebe wert und die haupt
fluchtbewegungen darüber führen
darum waren wir da gesehen
die wissen wie man das ist gegensatz zur
schau gestellte gebäude stehen kann ist
das ganz klar darüber ist locker wurde
stets haben das gefühl man müsse ganz
verkaufen
und noch einer dass über das jeder
machen das gibt etwa meister liegt
afrika zu sehen sei die
auseinandersetzung mit deutschland um
den fluglärm eskaliert ist zieht der
flughafen zürich als alternative
zusätzlich sogenannte südstaat geradeaus
in betracht das wollen die süd schnizer
verhindern
vom flughafen bewilligt trifft sich an
jedem ersten sonntag morgen im monat der
harte kern des vereins flugschneise süd
nein zur mahnwache
die kritik gilt weniger den reisenden
als vielmehr der flughafenpolitik
unserer sicht völlig unvernünftig
er möchte möglichst großer halb sie das
heißt nicht anders als dass man versucht
brown mit dumping preisen möglich blüte
nach zürich locker weil ich nie das im
sinn hat also schnell wie möglich wieder
zur wahl
mit dem rechten flügel und das haus
eigentlich nötig
die reisenden lassen sich von dieser
botschaft kaum abschrecken
der flughafen direktor thomas kern kennt
jedoch die problematik gerät selber im
süden des flughafens einzig lösung
entweder vom lansbury war man sich mit
deutschland hat die schöne einige und
beim tischler zeitlofs alte regime aber
ich muss ihnen sagen dass ich bis zur
strom wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlichkeit
dass deutschland die eu verschärft ist
viel größer
und je mehr druck von den konsum wird
das nach dem ausstieg müsse der vorgang
november 2013
während im kampf gegen den fluglärm
zurzeit stillstand herrscht nimmt bei
thomas morf ein anderes projekt form an
wolfs haben eine weltreise geplant das
datum der abreise ist fix auch wenn die
mission fluglärm nicht beendet ist
durch hitze welche sicherheitsbereich so
sieht ja sieht jahrzehnte voraus fest
dass man das im alltag machen
das ist heute groß ursprünglich war
thomas morf vermessungsingenieur und
machte später das diplom zum marketing
planer jetzt baut er diesen kemper aus
mit dem das ehepaar in wenigen wochen
eine mehrmonatige reise antreten wird
aber zuerst macht morf noch einmal mobil
diesmal mit einer petition an die
adresse von bundesrätin doris leuthard
ich werde das in ihrer medienmitteilung
entsprechend hoffen die fis abend zu
verbringen
wobei ich das wirklich möglichkeit haben
doch immer noch zeit aber so ist
eigentlich erwartet meyer burri und
esther haas vertreten dass fluglärm
geplagten quartier zürich schwamendingen
die interessensgemeinschaften haben
zusammen über 23.000 unterschriften
gegen die südstadt geradeaus gesammelt
doch wo genau soll die übergabe
stattfinden
dann haben wir denn ich sage es ist mir
doch dass dadurch die starken vorschrift
getreu werden die 23.000 unterschriften
auf gestapelt um 10 uhr ist eine
medienkonferenz geplant doch außer uns
ist noch kein journalist eingetroffen
matthias tut macht sich auf die suche
einige wochen später wird er sich als
nachfolger von thomas [ __ ] für das amt
des vfsn präsidenten zur verfügung
stellen
es ist zehn uhr kein medienvertreter ist
gekommen
trotzdem thomas morf sieht die sache
durch sehr verehrte damen und herren ich
möchte sie recht herzlich begrüßten
information verfügt und zwar arbeiten
mit position bezog stolz trägt mit 3 1
501 7 200 schriften oder bundeskanzler
frei für mit stolz trägt wird die
maximal mögliche anzahl manche mit dem
maximal größtmögliche programm belastet
sein
mein name ist hase ich bin präsident vom
verein flugschneise süd nein die hand
eine botschaft vorbereitet dafür werben
dass die unterlagen sie mit ok hand und
total unterschrift wo sie mir mit
geistern betroffen sind durch die kritik
mitarbeiter aus zuständigen departemente
und das bundesweite motto stehe
frau graf stellt sich für das
erinnerungsfoto der petitions
überbringer zur verfügung
die bundesrätin selber bekommen sie
nicht zu gesicht
in anspruch und ihnen gerne vorführen
hand ja extra aufs leere mobil
verzichtet aber ich möchte ihnen doch
ein ganz klein wenig holbrooke
sind der franken abgerechnet
[Gelächter]
so gelangen die 23.000 unterschriften
ins innere des bundeshauses dennoch die
truppe fühlt sich nicht ernst genommen
das ist der zeitpunkt der abreise hat
das haus in pausen ist geräumt bis zum
letzten tag hat thomas morf mobilisiert
vorträge gehalten politiker
sensibilisiert das büro ist immer noch
im betrieb absolviert und alles kann man
bekommt einfach mit
ich nehme
matthias doht lehnhof nachfolger als
vfsn präsident braucht einen tipp für
seine rede in seiner zehnjährigen
amtszeit als vfsn präsident gelang es
thomas morf weder mit
protestveranstaltungen noch mit
politischem lobbying und auch nicht auf
juristischem weg die süd schneise vom
lärm zu befreien
der vorwurf machen nicht alles manche
mögliche unternehmen das unternehmen
möglichkeiten um das zu verhindern oder
die situation verbessere lokal weiß
natürlich viel schöner wenn man eine
aufgabe erledigt ist aber ich kann eben
einfach müssen akzeptieren dass das nöte
so einfach ist und vor allem ist mir ab
und zu wirklich abheben medaillenkampf
mir mit dem zahnstocher und jahren die
große bronze die camper ist nun
aufgerüstet und nahezu startklar
dann haben wir die erste sand brachte
montiert die große persönlich hofft dass
in ihr wir brauchen weil das ich immer
wieder verbunden
dann haben wir da einen unterfahrschutz
gemacht wenn ich an unsere körper damit
er nicht in wabern gigantisch und da
vorne als auch noch habe da eine mobile
tanks und deren halter für vier kurze
ansprache in kurzer zeit werden esther
und thomas morf die schweiz hinter sich
lassen
das schiff in ancona ist gebucht bei der
planung hat noch bis ins kleinste detail
gedacht dass womöglich jede gute idee
gestalt zwei funktionen erfüllen weil
auch das resultat stimmt dann nicht
freude umso größer
vor der abreise besucht thomas morf
nochmal burri die präsidentin des
quartiervereins schwamendingen hat post
aus dem bundeshaus bekommen kreis
einziges vergnügen nur den kleinsten
verständnis für irgendwo da drüben 20
lose gruppe unterschrieben hat aber
dafür kapazität und komplexität und und
sie sah immer erhöhung der
sicherheitsreserven oder deshalb werden
zurzeit die südstadt geradeaus vertieft
untersucht
ihr habt sie unversöhnlich bundesrätin
leuthard will die südstadt als
alternative im programm behalten so
deuten meyer burri und thomas morf den
brief es ist einfach ich liebe mühe und
weil es sich doch extrem vielen vielen
fehlt negativ da aber nicht die letzte
zeit und es geht immer mit der autorin
zu suchen
also wann der flughafen wieder regen bis
aber ort
es taucht mit sehr vielen negativen
behaftet und das machen wir je länger
genehmigen muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
es ist märz 2014
der letzte abend als präsident des vfsn
an der heutigen generalversammlung nimmt
thomas morf abschied noch ist er ein
gefragter mann
es war nicht einfach einen nachfolger zu
finden
tritt matthias doht lee selbstständiger
elektriker aus zumikon das schwierige
erbe an
die serbische pro jahr für das gros der
trauer und der unterstützung wollten in
der vergangenen jahr über vor
ich wünsche mir eine kollegin vorstand
nachwuchs fehle nach was das sie vor die
gleiche unterstützung und christa braun
unberührt und gerade über kuba den iran
sind sehr komfortabel sein so endet
diese geschichte
thomas morf fälle ist die bühne der
kampf um den fluglärm geht ohne ihn
weiter im herzen wird er jedoch
weiterhin ein süd schnizer bleiben uns
erreicht nach einigen wochen seine video
grußbotschaft
sind jetzt wieder so lange bewohner
versucht die monika thürmer buch ist ein
schallschutz verbessert weil die
flugobjekt muss ich da einmal am tag
bewegen diese ihm vorschlug los